sonic he's made us laugh he has
certainly made us cry anyhow new video
game movies now so let's talk about that
[Music]
Sonic the Hedgehog
so Sonic the Hedgehog is a movie based
off of the video game Sonic the Hedgehog
it goes down generally how the trailer
shows this Sonic the Hedgehog is from
this other world then rings can create
portals and then he comes to our world
though it's a little different than that
I thought it was like oh he comes to our
world stranger in a strange land he's
actually been here for a while so he
does know the place he knows the
logistics he kind of knows how earth
operates there was less of a fish out of
water story that I thought it was gonna
be anyhow he teams up with James Marsden
who was a sheriff in the small town
called Green Hill Zone just green hills
not zoned but still solid reference to
the game anyhow so the smartest person
on earth dr. Robotnik played by Jim
Carrey he's like what is this new
creature
I need him today I have a buddy roadtrip
movie between Sonic and and James
Marsden which in terms of personality I
thought Ben Schwartz as Sonic the
Hedgehog who plays the voice of Sonic
the Hedgehog I thought it was great it
was what I wanted from Sonic the
Hedgehog he's not as trash taki as Sonic
is with his Thompson Super Smash
Brothers but he's fun loveable likable
in that because of my dog danger had a
voice he probably sound like Sonic
packaged dog gypsy probably Jack from
Mass Effect 2 I did the smart thing I
always do the smart thing if people [ __ ]
with me I also like James Marcin more to
the point I like the dialogue between
characters in his movie
whether it's dialogue between James
Morrison's character and Sonic the
Hedgehog or James marcin's character and
his wife or dr. Robotnik and anybody
he's being condescending and belittling
- I liked it also dr. Robotnik I liked
the energy Jim Carrey brought to this
movie I don't think it was any mystery
like no one should be surprised that Jim
Carrey's a standout in here this version
of dr. Robotnik's exactly what you think
Jim Carrey dr. Robotnik would be he
brings that Jim Carrey ISM that zany
animated Jim Carrey quality to dr.
Robotnik and he was having fun with it
by proxy you do have fun Jim Carrey has
always been good at that you've always
been able to see Jim Carrey have fun and
you're just having fun with him I will
see if the movie does borrow from
Quicksilver and Days of Future past it
has a moment like that which logically
would but I do
like someone watched Days of Future past
they were like oh we ever make Sonic
movie we should have a scene like that
in fact let's do it I mean it makes
sense it was cool in this movie too and
the movie makes you take a bit of a leap
they got to get to the West Coast they
got to get to San Francisco during green
hills not zone Montana but it
illustrates that sonic can run there in
about two seconds but he doesn't know
how to get to San Francisco so he needs
James Marston to be his guide or Sonic
could have just gotten a map but now
let's let's tag along with the human
that'll slow us down when a crazed
scientist who's trying to kill or
capture you is coming after you now the
theme of friendship is a huge part of
the movie so yeah maybe Sonic was like
well I could just run there by myself
and get a map and do it or I want to be
friends with this guy movie doesn't
outright say that's what happened but it
implies it so I'm just okay like I said
arguments gone the days of feature
passing the best from Days of Future
past you know I got to thank them for
fixing the sonic character design
initially in that first trailer that was
our sonic design and the internet had
quite a few things to say about it and
Internet we got to admit we weren't very
nice about it Internet collectively
voiced their opinion and neither the
director of the studio both either
whoever they were like okay we'll change
Sonic's design to a more Sonic the
Hedgehog's looking Sonic the Hedgehog
which is a little more cartoonish it
looks like the initial plan was like
let's make him look real ish
I know it's water into the bridge I
don't want to beat a dead horse about it
but I got to thank them for fixing it
because this movie does illustrate how
important creature and character design
is a couple times maybe a few times in
this movie I found myself thinking what
would this movie feel like if it was the
old character designed for Sonic the
Hedgehog and the answer is much worse
but not have worked the weird realistic
monstrosity character design would have
clashed with Jim Carrey's animated
cartoon villain vibe he's giving for dr.
Robotnik a fix Sonic the Hedgehog design
though more cartoonish completely works
with the vibe of the movie and the vibe
of the villain this is all a big lesson
on how important creature and character
design is and how it would could or will
fundamentally change the vibe of the
movie it works now it would not have
worked with that initial one anyhow
dodged a bullet there thank you to
everyone who had a hand in changing
Sonic's design or making that collar all
the visual effects artists who probably
put in a lot of overtime it paid off for
the better folks in the end simple
review simple movie I enjoyed Sonic the
Hedgehog I enjoyed what jim carrey
brought to doctor
I'm glad Sonic actually looks like Sonic
and not whatever that was I like Ben
Schwartz as Sonic I actually liked James
Marston as basically you know Sonic's
pal our eyes into the movie basically
it's a buddy roadtrip movie with the
fastest rodent ever it had good energy
it's a fun family movie a couple of
references from the game it doesn't rely
on those couple references to the games
but if you catch them that's fun too
thought it was a fun time no alcohol
required there is something in this
movie where I'm like it's not a Mushroom
Kingdom reference I'm not sure the movie
never says it is I don't know could be
one of those things they're like alright
we have that door there if Nintendo
wants to jump on board we could do some
video games or cinematic universe it's
there to use if they don't well we don't
have to use it in that capacity but
there is something that makes me a bit
curious about that right so Sonic the
Hedgehog the movie have you seen it what
did you think about it where does it
rank among your video game movie
hierarchy I mean granted they can't all
be as good as Van Damme Street Fighter
look raúl juliá
elevates that doesn't matter that's a
different conversation for another time
yes I'm curious about one other thing
Sonic doesn't like mushrooms in this
movie which hey maybe that's why I like
him cause mushrooms no but I do like
black licorice and I've noticed one or
the other with people people either love
mushrooms hate licorice or love licorice
hate mushrooms it's one or the other is
that how are you
whatever you think about everything I
just asked comment below let me know I'm
just curious and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want is
any more click right here to see more
[Music]